- Bienvenidos de nuevo a Entendiendo
la Información y Computación Cuántica.
Mi nombre es John Watrous y soy el director técnico
de IBM Quantum Education.
Esta es la tercera lección de la serie. En las dos primeras lecciones, hablamos sobre los fundamentos
de la información cuántica.
Primero para sistemas individuales de forma aislada y luego para múltiples sistemas.
También discutimos las mediciones en la
base estándar y las operaciones unitarias tanto en el contexto de
sistemas individuales como múltiples.
En esta lección, introduciremos
el modelo de circuit cuántico, que nos da una forma estándar de describir computaciones cuánticas,
y también podemos usar quantum circuits para describir protocolos cuánticos y otros tipos de interacciones que involucran múltiples dispositivos cuánticos.
Además de los quantum circuits, también discutiremos algunos
conceptos matemáticos importantes relacionados con la información cuántica,
y los usaremos para observar
algunas limitaciones fundamentales de la información cuántica y lo que podemos hacer con los quantum circuits.
Eso nos preparará bien para
la lección que sigue a esta, donde veremos algunos
ejemplos muy importantes y con eso concluiremos la
primera unidad de la serie
sobre los fundamentos de la información cuántica.
Aquí tienes un resumen de la lección. Empezaremos con el modelo de circuit cuántico y veremos cómo funciona.
Luego hablaremos sobre
la noción de producto interno, que es de crucial importancia, así como sobre la ortonormalidad y las proyecciones,
que están relacionadas con los productos internos. No discutimos estas cosas
en las dos primeras lecciones porque realmente no
las necesitábamos, pero ahora sí.
Los productos internos nos proporcionan
una herramienta matemática de la que simplemente no podemos prescindir.
Simplemente no podríamos avanzar mucho en la comprensión de la información y la
computación cuántica sin los productos internos.
Y en la tercera parte de la lección, echaremos un vistazo a
algunas limitaciones importantes de la información cuántica.
En última instancia, lo que queremos hacer es explorar cosas interesantes
que podemos hacer con la información cuántica, pero para hacerlo de manera efectiva,
necesitamos ser conscientes de algunas
cosas que no podemos hacer.
En particular, discutiremos
la noción de una fase global y por qué las fases globales son irrelevantes.
Veremos un enunciado del
teorema de no clonación, que nos dice que los estados cuánticos no pueden copiarse en general, y veremos que dos estados cuánticos
no pueden ser
discriminados perfectamente entre sí a menos que sean ortogonales, lo cual es una limitación fundamental que hay que tener en cuenta.
El primer tema de la lección
es el modelo de circuit cuántico, que es un modelo de computación
que nos proporciona una forma
de describir computaciones cuánticas.
El modelo de circuit cuántico se
basa en una noción más general en ciencias de la computación de un circuit, y puedes definir muchos
modelos de computación diferentes
basados en esta noción general.
La idea básica es que un
circuit está compuesto de cables que transportan información, y gates, que representan operaciones
que se aplican a la
información transportada por los cables.
El término circuit es en realidad
un nombre un poco extraño para este tipo de modelo,
porque la palabra circuit
generalmente se refiere a un
camino circular de algún tipo.
Pero cuando hablamos de circuits
como modelos de computación, generalmente hablamos
de circuits acíclicos
donde los caminos circulares no están permitidos.
Para ser más precisos, para los
propósitos de esta serie, vamos a exigir que
la información siempre fluya de izquierda a derecha en cualquier circuit.
Así que si prefieres, puedes
pensar en los circuits como descripciones de secuencias de operaciones donde el tiempo avanza de izquierda a derecha.
Aquí tienes un ejemplo de un circuit booleano donde los cables transportan
valores binarios, ya sea cero o uno,
y los gates representan
operaciones de lógica booleana.
Los cables están representados por líneas, y aquí tenemos dos bits
de entrada etiquetados como X e Y,
y si queremos saber
qué hace el circuit con una elección particular de entradas, propagamos los valores en
los cables de izquierda a derecha,
dependiendo de las acciones
que los gates tienen sobre los valores que son
transportados por los cables.
Por ejemplo, podemos
ver qué ocurre cuando empezamos con el cable de entrada superior configurado al valor uno y el cable de entrada inferior
configurado al valor cero.
Estos dos cables de entrada llevan
a estos dos puntos aquí, que representan operaciones de bifurcación, lo que significa que el valor se copia
para que pueda ser transportado
hacia adelante a lo largo de múltiples cables.
Así que si hacemos esto, entonces estos
dos cables toman el valor uno, que es el mismo que este uno, y estos dos cables toman el valor cero,
que es el mismo que este cero.
Aquí tenemos un gate NOT que
está indicado por el símbolo de negación lógica, así que el
valor que sale es un cero,
que es la negación lógica de uno. De manera similar, el valor
que sale de este gate es un uno, que es la
negación lógica de cero.
Estos dos gates son gates AND,
este gate es un gate OR, y si continuamos
y propagamos los valores
a través del circuit, evaluando
los gates de manera apropiada, entonces vemos que el valor final
en este cable aquí es un uno.
Entonces, el circuit completo describe
una secuencia de operaciones que se componen como sugiere la figura, y terminamos con una función
de dos bits a un bit
en este caso particular. Pero en general, puede haber cualquier número
de bits de entrada y salida.
Este circuit en particular resulta calcular el OR exclusivo de los dos bits de entrada, por lo que la salida es uno
si y solo si exactamente
uno de los dos bits de entrada está en uno y el otro está en cero, pero eso no es realmente
importante, es solo un ejemplo.
Es un hecho básico sobre los circuits booleanos que cualquier función de cualquier número de bits a cualquier número de bits puede ser calculada
por algún circuit booleano, aunque a veces puede que
necesites un circuit muy grande para calcular la función
que te interesa.
Hay otros estilos que
se usan para describir circuits.
Por ejemplo, esta figura
representa exactamente el mismo circuit que teníamos antes, usando un estilo que quizás es más típico
en ingeniería eléctrica, donde hay convenciones para las formas que representan diferentes gates.
No vamos a usar
este estilo en particular, pero sí introduciremos
algunos símbolos propios para diferentes quantum gates, como Hadamard gates,
Controlled NOT gates,
Toffoli gates, y demás.
Solo como nota al margen, aquí podemos ver el origen
del término circuit.
En el contexto de la ingeniería eléctrica, es muy natural
pensar en la electricidad que circula por un circuit.
Pero en esta serie no
estamos hablando de electricidad moviéndose por circuits, sino de información
moviéndose por circuits.
Y una vez más para nosotros, siempre serán acíclicos, donde la información
se mueve de izquierda a derecha.
Aquí hay un ejemplo diferente de
un tipo distinto de circuit llamado circuit aritmético.
Esta vez los cables almacenan números y los gates representan
operaciones aritméticas como la suma y la multiplicación.
Aquí puedes ver un ejemplo
de un circuit aritmético.
No es importante para los fines
de esta lección lo que hace, es solo un ejemplo que
pretende transmitir la idea de que existen diferentes
nociones de circuits.
También podemos pensar en
circuits que involucren aleatoriedad, por ejemplo, donde los gates representan
operaciones probabilísticas, y si quisieras,
probablemente podrías pasarte todo el día imaginando nuevos modelos de computación basados en la noción de circuits.
En el modelo de quantum circuit,
los cables representan Qubits, y los gates representan tanto operaciones unitarias como mediciones.
Aquí hay un ejemplo muy sencillo
de un quantum circuit.
Hay solo un Qubit en este circuit, que está representado
por la línea horizontal, y los gates, que están
indicados por cuadrados,
representan operaciones unitarias que se realizan sobre este Qubit.
Por lo que no hay mediciones
en este ejemplo en particular.
Si queremos darle al
Qubit un nombre como X, podemos indicarlo en el diagrama poniendo una X justo
aquí, eso es opcional.
Al igual que con el circuit booleano de hace un momento, podemos pensar en este circuit
como una secuencia de operaciones donde el tiempo
avanza de izquierda a derecha.
Así que empezamos con X,
aplicamos el primer gate, que es un Hadamard gate
seguido de un S gate,
luego otro Hadamard
gate, y finalmente un T gate.
Vimos estas operaciones
hacia el final de la lección uno, y aquí puedes ver
sus descripciones matriciales.
Así que cuando realizamos estas
cuatro operaciones en orden, es decir, primero H, luego
S, luego H de nuevo, y luego T,
la operación combinada está dada
por este producto de aquí, teniendo en cuenta que el orden
esencialmente se invierte
como comentamos en la lección uno. Si realizamos la multiplicación matricial, obtenemos esta matriz de aquí,
y por lo tanto la acción del
circuit sobre el Qubit X está descrita por esta matriz unitaria.
A veces nos gustaría indicar explícitamente en un diagrama de quantum circuit
qué entrada estamos introduciendo, y podemos hacerlo como ves justo aquí.
En este caso, estamos introduciendo
Ket 0 en el circuit.
Eso es bastante común. Solemos tomar Ket 0 como
el estado inicializado de un Qubit, pero no es obligatorio.
También podríamos considerar
aplicar el circuit a un estado diferente.
Si queremos, también podemos
indicar el estado de salida que obtenemos, así.
Aquí hay otro ejemplo donde
esta vez tenemos dos Qubits llamados X e Y como
puedes ver en el diagrama.
Aquí tenemos un Hadamard gate, que se aplica al Qubit Y, seguido del gate que está indicado por
este símbolo de aquí,
que es un Controlled NOT gate. Hablamos de la
operación Controlled NOT en la lección anterior,
y aquí en este diagrama podemos
ver que el Qubit de control es Y, que está indicado por
el pequeño círculo relleno,
y el Qubit objetivo es X, que está indicado por el círculo grande con lo que parece un signo más dentro.
Se parece un poco al
símbolo del OR exclusivo, así que tiene sentido.
Puedes imaginar que cualquier
estado clásico almacenado en Y se aplica con XOR sobre el Qubit X.
Y solo en aras de la claridad, aquí está el diagrama que
muestra la acción de este gate sobre los estados de la base estándar,
donde suponemos que A
y B son valores binarios.
Para otros estados, la acción está determinada
por la linealidad, como siempre.
Ahora, antes de continuar, será útil
establecer explícitamente una convención que vamos a seguir respecto a cómo se ordenan los Qubits
en los diagramas de quantum circuit como este.
Y la convención es que
el orden de abajo hacia arriba en un diagrama de quantum circuit equivale al orden de izquierda a derecha
como en una tupla o un producto tensorial.
Esa es una convención que
seguiremos en la serie y también es la convención
que se usa en Qiskit.
Entonces, para este circuit en particular, lo estamos pensando como
actuando sobre un par de Qubits X, Y,
X va primero porque está abajo, e Y va al final o en segundo lugar en este caso, porque está arriba.
Una forma de visualizarlo,
por si te ayuda, es imaginar que rotás
este circuit en sentido horario para que las entradas queden arriba
y las salidas queden abajo, y el orden de los
Qubits será correcto.
A veces este orden confunde a la gente, así que asegurate de tener
esta convención en mente.
Entonces, cuando pensamos en la acción que describe este circuit, lo primero que tenemos es un
Hadamard gate aplicado a Y
y luego un gate Controlled NOT
sobre los dos Qubits con Y siendo el control
y X siendo el objetivo.
Si queremos escribir una matriz unitaria que describa la acción combinada
de estos dos gates, podemos hacerlo.
Primero, consideramos el Hadamard gate en Y.
Le estamos aplicando el Hadamard gate a Y y no hacemos nada a X, lo que equivale a
realizar una operación identidad en X.
Entonces la acción del Hadamard gate sobre ambos Qubits juntos está
dada por el producto tensorial de la matriz identidad y
la matriz que representa
la operación Hadamard en Y.
Eso se ve así, teniendo en cuenta nuestra
convención de que X va primero e Y va segundo, así que es
la identidad tensorializada con H.
Luego aplicamos la
operación Controlled NOT, que tiene esta representación
matricial, y nuevamente, eso es consistente con nuestra convención.
El segundo Qubit Y es el control y el primer Qubit X es el objetivo.
No tengas miedo de pausar el video y verificar que esto tiene sentido, y voy a dejar de recordártelo.
Podés pausar estos videos, volver atrás y ver partes
todas las veces que quieras, ajustar la velocidad de reproducción si lo preferís, usarlos de la forma
que mejor te funcione.
De todas formas, cuando componemos las
dos operaciones juntas, la acción combinada está descrita
por este producto aquí,
y estas dos matrices se
multiplican en este orden porque el Hadamard se realiza primero y el Controlled NOT
se realiza segundo,
y una vez más, esto es consistente
con lo que hablamos en la lección uno, donde el orden
esencialmente se invierte.
Si realizamos la multiplicación matricial, obtenemos esta matriz aquí.
Y ahora podemos leer de esta matriz lo que hace el circuit con
los estados de la base estándar.
Si ejecutamos el circuit con la entrada 0, 0, es decir Ket 0 para el primer Qubit, Ket 0 para el segundo Qubit,
el resultado es el estado de Bell Phi+, que podemos ver en la
primera columna de la matriz.
Si introducimos 0, 1, obtenemos el estado Phi-, uno cero nos da el estado Si+,
y 1, 1 nos da no Psi-, sino -1 X Psi-.
El signo menos no es
realmente significativo aquí. Si no quisieras que estuviera, podrías realizar una operación swap
sobre los dos Qubits
para eliminarlo y no
afectarías lo que pasó con los primeros tres estados de la base estándar.
Pero realmente no es importante
para los fines de este ejemplo.
Entonces, en resumen, el circuit tiene esta acción aquí sobre los estados de la base estándar.
Cuando estás pensando en
lo que hace un circuit en particular, no necesitás pasar por
la conversión a matrices y multiplicarlas,
también podés rastrear la
acción que el circuit tiene sobre estados particulares, y en muchos casos esta será
la opción preferida.
En este ejemplo, por ejemplo, podemos ver lo que hace el circuit
con el estado 0, 0 examinando la acción de los gates.
El estado inicial, que
llamamos Pi cero aquí, solo para evitar un nombre
que sería confuso con los estados de Bell, es 0, 0.
Aplicamos el Hadamard gate y el estado que obtenemos es 0+ que podemos expandir así,
y luego la operación Controlled NOT lleva este estado al estado Phi+, lo que podemos ver pensando
en la acción que el Controlled NOT tiene sobre
los estados de la base estándar,
Y podés hacer lo mismo
para los otros tres estados de la base estándar o cualquier
otro estado.
También podemos incorporar bits clásicos en los diagramas de quantum circuit.
Se indican con
líneas dobles como ves en este diagrama.
Es decir, A y B son bits clásicos y X e Y son Qubits.
Tenemos los mismos dos gates unitarios que en el ejemplo anterior, y estos símbolos aquí representan mediciones en la base estándar
Específicamente, después de que se realizan las dos
operaciones unitarias, se realiza una medición en la base estándar
sobre Y
y el resultado se escribe
en el bit clásico B, y de manera similar X se mide y el resultado se escribe en el bit A.
Aquí podés ver que los Qubits X e Y continúan después de ser medidos.
Es bastante común,
sin embargo, que no nos importe demasiado los Qubits
después de ser medidos.
A veces solo nos importa
el resultado de la medición. Y en un caso así, podemos usar el estilo abreviado
que ves aquí
donde las mediciones tienen Qubits entrando y bits clásicos saliendo.
Lo que hay que entender aquí es que
una vez que se miden los qubits, simplemente se descartan o se ignoran y el resultado
de la medición clásica es lo que se lleva adelante.
A medida que la serie continúa, veremos muchos
ejemplos de quantum circuits y por lo general
serán mucho más complicados que los ejemplos
muy simples que acabamos de ver.
Como mencioné antes, se usan símbolos
distintos para diferentes gates.
Los gates de un solo qubit generalmente
se escriben como cuadrados con una letra que indica
cuál es la operación.
A veces estos diferentes
gates tienen código de colores para significar cosas distintas, pero
lo ignoraremos por ahora.
Ya hemos visto el
gate Controlled NOT.
Los Swap gates se representan
como ves aquí, y los Toffoli gates y los Fredkin gates
se representan como ves aquí.
Recuerda que un Toffoli gate es un gate Controlled Controlled NOT y un Fredkin gate es
un gate de swap controlado.
Entonces estos símbolos son
coherentes con la idea de que un qubit de control se
indica con un círculo sólido con una línea que lo conecta
al gate que controla.
En general, los qubits controlados
no tienen que estar arriba, y estos gates no tienen
que actuar sobre qubits adyacentes, lo que significa que estos gates
pueden extenderse a través de
otros qubits sobre los que no actúan, y veremos eso
ocurriendo en lecciones futuras.
Una cosa más que solemos hacer cuando usamos el modelo de quantum circuit es ver operaciones unitarias arbitrarias
sobre cualquier número de qubits
como si fueran gates individuales, como ves aquí.
Simplemente dibujando un rectángulo con una etiqueta que corresponda
a la operación unitaria de que se trate.
En este caso es alguna
operación unitaria U.
Claro, no sabemos
qué es U a partir de este diagrama; tenemos que asumir que
U está definida de alguna manera, o que estamos considerando alguna
operación unitaria arbitraria
U, quizás. Podría ser, por ejemplo, que
simplemente queramos pensar en U como si fuera una subrutina,
en aras de la claridad.
También usamos esta notación
que ves aquí para una operación U controlada,
donde el qubit de control se indica con un círculo sólido
igual que antes.
Así que esa es una breve introducción
al modelo de quantum circuit. Y como dije antes, veremos muchos más
ejemplos de quantum circuits
a medida que avancemos en la serie.
En la siguiente parte de la lección, vamos a ver
los productos internos, la ortonormalidad y las proyecciones, que son nociones muy importantes
en la información y la computación cuánticas.
Empezaremos con los productos internos.
Recuerda que cuando usamos
la notación de Dirac, un Ket es un vector columna
y un Bra es un vector fila,
y específicamente el
vector Bra correspondiente a un vector columna dado es la transpuesta conjugada
de ese vector columna.
Entonces para este vector de aquí, obtenemos el vector Bra correspondiente transponiendo el vector
como si fuera una matriz,
lo que equivale a acostarlo de lado y luego tomar el conjugado complejo de cada una de las entradas.
Ahora, supongamos que tenemos dos Kets con el mismo número de entradas como este.
Si formamos este bracket aquí, que simplemente significa que
tomamos el producto del Bra y el Ket,
como si fueran matrices,
entonces obtenemos esta expresión
que ves aquí, que es un escalar, o en
otras palabras un número complejo.
Este valor se llama el producto
interno de estos dos vectores.
También puedes pensar en los productos internos en términos de vectores de la
forma que ves aquí, donde los vectores se expresan
como combinaciones lineales
de vectores de la base estándar.
El producto interno de estos vectores se define de la misma manera que
antes, Bra Psi por Ket Phi, lo que podemos expresar
como un producto como este.
Y si calculamos y simplificamos, nos queda esta expresión aquí para el producto interno, que es análoga a lo que teníamos antes,
excepto que esta vez estamos
tomando la suma sobre los elementos de nuestro conjunto de estados clásicos, que es sigma en este caso particular.
Aquí hay un ejemplo pensado para darte una imagen geométrica de
cómo funcionan los productos internos.
Aquí he dibujado un círculo
en un espacio bidimensional correspondiente a un qubit, y siempre que restrinjamos nuestra atención
a vectores con entradas de números reales, podemos dibujarlos como puntos en este plano.
Tomemos Phi como
este vector de aquí.
Es un vector unitario, lo que podemos ver
calculando la norma euclidiana, y eso es lo que representa este círculo,
son todos los vectores unitarios
con entradas de números reales.
Digamos también que Psi es
este vector de aquí, que nuevamente también es un vector unitario.
De hecho es el estado menos, pero aquí lo llamamos simplemente Psi.
Si calculamos el producto
interno de estos dos vectores, obtenemos uno menos la raíz cuadrada de tres sobre dos por raíz de dos,
que resulta ser aproximadamente -1/4.
El valor de este producto interno es igual al coseno del ángulo
entre los dos vectores, como puedes ver aquí en la figura.
Eso es algo que es
cierto en general para los vectores unitarios. Si tenemos dos vectores unitarios y ambos tienen entradas de números reales,
entonces el producto interno entre ellos es igual al coseno del
ángulo entre ellos.
En particular, si el producto
interno es igual a cero, como en este ejemplo, donde hemos cambiado Psi para que sea
este estado de aquí,
entonces los dos vectores deben
estar en un ángulo de 90 grados entre sí.
Todo esto se generaliza a
vectores de cualquier dimensión, por cierto, siempre que las
entradas sean números reales, no es solo para vectores bidimensionales.
Si tenemos entradas de números complejos, la imagen ya no
funciona realmente, pero aun así, el producto interior es igual de
útil como veremos.
El producto interior tiene algunas
propiedades muy importantes y vamos a tomarnos unos momentos para observar algunas de esas propiedades ahora.
Primero hay una conexión
entre el producto interior y la norma euclidiana.
Si tomamos el producto interior
de cualquier vector consigo mismo, obtenemos la norma euclidiana al cuadrado.
Así que también podemos decir que la norma euclidiana de un vector es igual a la raíz
cuadrada del producto interior
de ese vector consigo mismo. Esto no es una coincidencia, es
una conexión fundamental, y aquí podemos ver que si no tuviéramos
los conjugados complejos en la definición del producto interior, entonces esta fórmula
ya no sería verdadera, y no tendríamos una noción tan útil
con esta conexión fundamental
con la norma euclidiana.
A continuación, el producto interior
es conjugado simétrico, lo que significa que si intercambiamos
el orden de los dos argumentos, el valor que obtenemos para el
producto interior se conjuga.
Eso se expresa mediante
esta ecuación de aquí y es bastante directo ver por qué sucede esto para estas dos expresiones
del producto interior de los dos vectores en los dos órdenes posibles.
El producto interior es lineal
en el segundo argumento. Concretamente, si definimos un vector Phi como esta combinación
lineal de dos vectores,
Phi uno y Phi dos, entonces el producto interior de
cualquier vector Psi con Phi es la misma combinación lineal
de los dos productos interiores,
y esto se desprende bastante
directamente del hecho de que la multiplicación de matrices es lineal.
Y también tenemos que el producto
interior es conjugado lineal en el primer argumento, lo cual puedes ver expresado aquí mismo.
Si Psi es esta combinación
lineal de vectores, entonces si tomamos el producto
interior de Psi y Phi,
entonces Bra Psi se convierte en este vector que vemos aquí donde tomamos el conjugado
complejo de beta uno y beta dos,
y así este es el resultado y eso es lo que se quiere decir
con linealidad conjugada.
Y la última propiedad del producto interior que quiero mencionar es
la increíblemente útil desigualdad de Cauchy-Schwarz.
Para dos vectores cualesquiera, Psi y Phi, el valor absoluto del producto interior nunca puede ser mayor que el
producto de las normas euclidianas
de los dos vectores. Y además, la única forma en que los dos
lados de la desigualdad pueden ser iguales es si los dos
vectores son linealmente dependientes,
lo que significa que uno de ellos es igual a algún escalar multiplicado por el otro.
Esta es de hecho una de las
desigualdades más ampliamente usadas en toda la matemática y
la usamos una y otra vez cuando hablamos de
información cuántica,
así que es muy bueno conocerla.
A continuación, hablaremos sobre las
nociones de ortogonalidad y ortonormalidad, que están
relacionadas con los productos interiores
y específicamente, con
productos interiores de vectores iguales a cero.
Para ser precisos, si tenemos
dos vectores, Psi y Phi, decimos que son ortogonales
si su producto interior
es igual a cero. Y la forma en que podemos pensar
en los vectores ortogonales intuitivamente es que están
en ángulo recto entre sí,
o alternativamente, que son
perpendiculares entre sí.
A veces la gente usa el término ortogonal para referirse a cosas que no tienen
nada que ver entre sí, como decir que un problema
es ortogonal a otro,
pero eso es obviamente bastante informal y no realmente significativo
en un sentido matemático, aunque la conexión es clara si piensas en los vectores ortogonales como apuntando
no en direcciones opuestas, sino en direcciones completamente diferentes como norte versus oeste, por ejemplo.
Si tenemos un conjunto de vectores, decimos que el conjunto es ortogonal si dos vectores distintos cualesquiera
elegidos de ese conjunto
son necesariamente ortogonales entre sí, lo cual podemos expresar
como ves aquí,
Un conjunto ortonormal es
simplemente un conjunto ortogonal de vectores unitarios.
Los vectores en conjuntos ortogonales
no necesariamente tienen que ser vectores unitarios, y de hecho podrías
incluso tener el vector cero
como elemento de un conjunto ortogonal, pero en un conjunto ortonormal, cada vector debe ser un vector unitario
además del
requisito de que el conjunto sea un conjunto ortogonal.
Dado lo que sabemos sobre la relación entre el producto interior
y la norma euclidiana, podemos expresar esta
condición de forma bastante concisa
como ves aquí.
Y por último, una base ortonormal es simplemente un conjunto
ortonormal que forma una base para el espacio vectorial
del que estamos hablando.
Por ejemplo, si tomamos cualquier
conjunto de estados clásicos sigma y pensamos en el conjunto de
todos los vectores de la base estándar,
vemos que este es un conjunto ortonormal y de hecho es una base ortonormal para el espacio de todos los vectores cuyas entradas corresponden a
este conjunto de estados clásicos sigma.
Todos estos son vectores unitarios y
son ortogonales por pares, así que es un conjunto ortonormal.
y como también es una base, tenemos que es una base ortonormal.
Los conjuntos ortonormales son
siempre linealmente independientes, por cierto, así que siempre que
tengas un conjunto ortonormal, siempre será una base ortonormal
para algún subespacio,
pero en este caso, tenemos una base para el espacio completo con el que estamos trabajando.
Otro ejemplo es el conjunto
que contiene Ket+ y Ket-.
Estos dos vectores son ortogonales, su producto interno es igual a cero.
y ambos son vectores unitarios y abarcan el
espacio bidimensional de vectores correspondiente a un solo qubit, así que forman una base
ortonormal para ese espacio.
Otro ejemplo es la base de Bell, que es una base ortonormal para el espacio de todos
los vectores de cuatro dimensiones correspondientes a dos qubits.
El conjunto que contiene Ket 0
y Ket+, en cambio, no es un conjunto ortogonal porque el producto interno entre
estos vectores no es cero.
Ambos son vectores unitarios y esto es una base para el espacio vectorial correspondiente a un qubit, pero no tenemos ortogonalidad.
Aquí hay un dato útil sobre los conjuntos ortonormales que usaremos de vez en cuando.
Supón que tenemos algún
conjunto ortonormal de vectores; concretamente, supongamos
que tenemos M vectores en este conjunto, Psi uno hasta Psi M,
donde asumimos que estos vectores pertenecen a algún espacio
vectorial de N dimensiones, o en otras palabras, cada uno de
los vectores tiene M entradas.
Como ya mencioné, los conjuntos ortonormales siempre son
linealmente independientes, así que no puede ser que M sea mayor que N,
pero podría ser que M sea menor que N, y ese es el caso que
nos interesa.
Y lo que establece este hecho es
que si M es menor que N, entonces siempre es posible
añadir vectores adicionales
al conjunto con el que empezamos para obtener una
base ortonormal para nuestro espacio.
Para ser precisos, necesariamente
deben existir vectores Psi M+1 hasta Psi N de modo que toda la colección
forme una base ortonormal.
Así que nunca puedes acorralarte
a ti mismo, por así decirlo, eligiendo de alguna forma un
conjunto ortonormal de vectores que no pueda extenderse para
formar una base ortonormal.
A veces puedes simplemente mirar
el conjunto con el que empiezas y descubrir cómo extenderlo para formar una base ortonormal, pero una alternativa que siempre funciona
es usar un procedimiento conocido como el proceso de
ortonormalización de Gram-Schmidt para construir estos vectores.
No voy a explicar ese
procedimiento en esta lección ni en esta serie porque los detalles específicos no
son realmente importantes para nosotros, pero por supuesto puedes buscarlo
si tienes curiosidad.
Es algo que puede
realizar una computadora en caso de que eso sea relevante, así que
no hay creatividad involucrada, es simplemente un procedimiento mecánico.
Una de las razones por las que este
es un dato tan útil tiene que ver con la estrecha conexión que existe entre las bases
ortonormales y las matrices unitarias.
En particular, para cualquier matriz cuadrada U, las tres condiciones que ves aquí son siempre equivalentes,
lo que significa que todas son
verdaderas o todas son falsas.
La primera condición dice
que U es una matriz unitaria, lo que significa que tanto U dagger por U como U por U dagger son ambas
iguales a la matriz identidad.
La segunda condición
dice que las filas de U forman una base ortonormal
y la tercera condición dice que las columnas de U
forman una base ortonormal.
En realidad no es tan difícil
ver por qué esta equivalencia es verdadera.
Solo para simplificar las cosas, veamos una
matriz U de tres por tres como ves aquí, donde las entradas pueden ser cualquier
número complejo que quieras.
Aquí en el lado izquierdo he escrito U conjugada transpuesta
simplemente por conveniencia.
Si formamos tres vectores
a partir de las columnas de U, que aquí se llaman Psi
uno, Psi dos y Psi tres, entonces si calculamos el
producto de U dagger y U,
puedes comprobar que cada
entrada del producto viene dada por un producto interno de vectores como vemos aquí en este patrón.
Y ahora cuando piensas en la condición de que U es unitaria, lo cual es equivalente a que esta matriz sea igual a la matriz identidad,
ves que es equivalente
a que los tres vectores formen un conjunto ortonormal.
Las entradas de la diagonal deben ser
todas iguales a uno, así que estos son necesariamente vectores unitarios, y las entradas fuera de la diagonal
deben ser cero,
así que es un conjunto ortogonal de vectores.
Entonces que U sea unitaria es equivalente a que las columnas formen un conjunto ortonormal,
Y eso tiene que ser una base porque el número de vectores en el conjunto, que es tres en este caso, coincide con la dimensión del espacio
en el que estamos trabajando. Puedes seguir un argumento similar para las filas en lugar de las columnas para concluir que U siendo
unitaria es equivalente
a que las filas formen una base ortonormal.
No funciona de manera tan sencilla porque tenemos que hacer un ajuste para que los conjugados complejos
funcionen de la manera correcta, pero la idea es la misma.
Una forma alternativa de abordarlo, que es bastante directa, es demostrar que una matriz es unitaria si y solo si su transpuesta es unitaria.
Y aquí sí quiero decir transpuesta y no transpuesta conjugada.
Es bastante trivial a partir de la
definición de matrices unitarias que la transpuesta conjugada
de cualquier matriz unitaria es unitaria,
pero también es cierto que la transpuesta de cualquier matriz unitaria es unitaria.
En cualquier caso, tenemos la
equivalencia entre estas tres condiciones para cualquier matriz cuadrada U, y podemos combinar esta equivalencia
con el hecho de que
los conjuntos ortonormales pueden extenderse para formar bases ortonormales, con el fin de construir matrices unitarias
que hagan cosas interesantes
o cumplan diversas necesidades que podamos encontrar.
Específicamente, cada vez que
tenemos un conjunto ortonormal de M vectores, siempre existirá una matriz unitaria U
cuyas primeras M columnas sean los vectores de ese conjunto ortonormal.
Las columnas restantes
siempre se pueden rellenar para obtener una matriz unitaria eligiéndolas de modo que las columnas formen
una base ortonormal. Este será un dato bastante
útil para tener a nuestra disposición.
Y un tema más para
esta sección de la lección es la noción de proyección.
Se dice que una matriz cuadrada Pi
es una proyección o una matriz de proyección si las dos propiedades que
se enumeran aquí son ambas verdaderas.
Esto es una Pi mayúscula, por cierto; es una elección bastante típica para la letra que se usa para denotar una proyección.
A menudo les damos estos nombres típicos a objetos como las matrices simplemente para que sean más fáciles de reconocer y para no confundirlos entre sí,
pero puedes usar el nombre que quieras. De todas formas, la primera condición es que Pi es igual a su propia transpuesta conjugada.
En general, cuando tenemos una matriz que es igual a su propia
transpuesta conjugada, decimos que es una matriz Hermitiana.
Así que la primera condición puede formularse alternativamente como que Pi es Hermitiana.
La segunda condición es
que si elevamos Pi al cuadrado, es decir, si multiplicamos Pi
por sí misma, obtenemos Pi de nuevo.
Así que elevar Pi al cuadrado no le hace nada.
La idea de una proyección,
intuitivamente hablando, es que es similar en
espíritu a proyectar una imagen sobre una pantalla o a trazar
una perpendicular sobre una recta
por ejemplo. Cuando multiplicas un
vector por una proyección, lo que estás haciendo es, en cierto sentido,
dejar una parte de él intacta
y anular el resto.
Así que si aplicas una
proyección una segunda vez, no hace nada porque
ya has anulado la parte que la proyección anula.
Un ejemplo de proyección
es esta matriz de aquí para cualquier elección de un vector unitario Psi.
Podemos comprobar que satisface
las condiciones requeridas una por una.
Para la primera, calculamos
la transpuesta conjugada, y esta es la transpuesta conjugada
de un producto.
Así que podemos usar esta fórmula de aquí para la transpuesta conjugada
de un producto como ayuda.
Lo que obtienes es el producto
de las transpuestas conjugadas, pero el orden se invierte.
Eso ocurre a causa de
la parte de la transposición.
Así que si aplicamos esa fórmula, obtenemos esta igualdad de aquí y luego podemos simplificar para
recuperar la matriz original.
Observa, por cierto, que no usamos el hecho
de que Psi es un vector unitario.
De hecho, esta matriz es
Hermitiana para cualquier vector Psi, no solo para vectores unitarios.
Y para la segunda, elevamos Pi al cuadrado y obtenemos
esta expresión de aquí, que es igual a la
matriz original esta vez
porque Psi es un vector unitario, así que este producto interior
de aquí es igual a uno, y ahí es donde entra en juego la suposición
de que Psi es un vector unitario
en la demostración.
Podemos generalizar este ejemplo y partir de un conjunto ortonormal.
Y si formamos esta matriz de aquí, donde sumamos las proyecciones correspondientes a los vectores individuales, obtenemos una proyección.
En la pantalla puedes ver los cálculos que lo demuestran, y te dejo que
los examines si lo deseas.
Y de forma similar a la
del primer ejemplo, es en la segunda condición donde se usa la ortonormalidad
del conjunto.
Lo que hace esta proyección si
la multiplicas por un vector es proyectar ese
vector sobre el subespacio generado por este conjunto de vectores,
lo cual de forma abstracta es
como trazar una perpendicular a ese subespacio, y una vez
que estás en ese subespacio, la proyección no hace nada.
Así que matrices como estas son
ejemplos de proyecciones, y de hecho ahora hemos agotado
todas las posibilidades.
Toda matriz de proyección tiene esta forma para alguna elección de un conjunto ortonormal.
La matriz cero es una proyección, así que tenemos que
asegurarnos de incluirla si queremos obtener todas las proyecciones.
Así que para ser claro al respecto, estamos permitiendo la
posibilidad de que M sea igual a cero, lo que nos da una suma vacía,
que podemos interpretar como la matriz cero.
Ahora que tenemos el
concepto de proyección a nuestra disposición, podemos definir una clase más general
de mediciones cuánticas conocidas como mediciones proyectivas.
Esta no es la noción más general
de medición, pero es significativamente más general que las mediciones en la base estándar
y va a ser muy
útil incorporarla a nuestra descripción
de la información cuántica.
Una medición proyectiva está definida por cualquier conjunto de proyecciones
que satisface la condición que ves aquí, que es que las proyecciones
suman la matriz identidad.
Aquí M puede ser cualquier
entero positivo que quieras, siempre que todas estas sean proyecciones y esta condición sea verdadera,
la colección define una
medición proyectiva.
La medición descrita
por tal colección funciona de la siguiente manera cuando
mides cualquier estado cuántico Psi.
Primero obtienes un resultado
entre uno y M, donde M es el número de proyecciones.
Para cada posible resultado K, la probabilidad de obtener ese resultado es la norma euclidiana
al cuadrado del vector que obtienes
al multiplicar S por Pi
K, la K-ésima proyección.
También podemos escribir esta
cantidad como ves aquí.
Esta igualdad proviene de la relación entre la norma euclidiana
y el producto interior, junto con el hecho
de que Pi K es una proyección.
A partir de la segunda forma, junto con la condición que tenemos sobre estas proyecciones, podemos ver de inmediato, por linealidad, que nuestras probabilidades
siempre sumarán uno,
teniendo en cuenta que Psi
debe ser un vector unitario.
Y segundo, suponiendo que
obtenemos el resultado K, el estado del sistema
colapsa al estado cuántico que obtenemos normalizando el vector
que obtuvimos al proyectar.
Veremos algunos
ejemplos en un momento, pero antes de hacerlo, déjame mencionar que en realidad no necesitamos
numerar los posibles
resultados del uno al M. Podemos elegir los nombres o símbolos que queramos para los resultados.
En particular, si tenemos una colección de proyecciones etiquetadas con símbolos
de algún conjunto gamma, digamos,
y satisfacen la
misma condición que antes, que es que su suma
es igual a la matriz identidad, entonces tenemos una medición proyectiva
que funciona exactamente
de la misma manera que antes.
La única diferencia aquí es que estamos permitiendo
que los resultados de la medición sean elementos de este conjunto gamma, en lugar de los enteros del uno al M.
Para nuestro primer ejemplo de
una medición proyectiva, observemos que
las mediciones en la base estándar son mediciones proyectivas.
En este caso, el conjunto de
resultados de la medición es el mismo que el conjunto de estados clásicos del sistema que se está midiendo.
Y el conjunto de proyecciones
que describe la medición es esta colección aquí, suponiendo que sigma es
el conjunto de estados clásicos
de nuestro sistema. Todas estas son proyecciones
y si las sumamos, obtenemos la matriz identidad, así que es una medición proyectiva válida.
Para ver cómo funciona esto con
un poco más de detalle, supongamos que
tenemos algún estado arbitrario escrito en la forma
que ves aquí.
La probabilidad de que la
medición dé el resultado A, según la descripción
de hace un momento, es este valor aquí,
que es igual al
valor absoluto al cuadrado de la entrada correspondiente
del vector Psi, que es lo que esperamos.
Condicionado a que el resultado sea A, el estado del sistema pasa a ser este, de nuevo, según la
descripción de hace un momento.
Si simplificamos, no obtenemos
exactamente el estado que esperamos, que es Ket A.
En cambio, obtenemos Ket A
multiplicado por un escalar, y concretamente, es un escalar con
valor absoluto igual a uno,
así que es un número complejo
sobre el círculo unitario.
Esto se llama fase global y hablaremos de las fases globales en breve, pero por ahora, en resumen, este
estado es equivalente a Ket A.
Esta fase global en realidad
no tiene ninguna significancia y veremos por qué
cuando lleguemos a la discusión de las fases globales.
Así que, dejando de lado este tema de las fases globales, del que hablaremos en un momento, vemos que las mediciones en la base estándar
son de hecho mediciones proyectivas. Como otro ejemplo, que en realidad es una extensión
del ejemplo anterior,
si realizamos una medición en la base estándar
sobre un sistema X y no hacemos nada al sistema Y, tal como hablamos
en la lección anterior,
es completamente equivalente
a medir el sistema X, Y.
Con esta medición proyectiva
de aquí.
Tenemos estas proyecciones correspondientes a los estados clásicos de X y las tensorizamos con la identidad en Y
lo cual refleja el hecho de que
no estamos haciendo nada a Y.
La descripción de cómo
funcionan las mediciones proyectivas en general nos dice
qué ocurre en este ejemplo, y te dejo a ti
comprobar que esto es de hecho
completamente equivalente a lo que discutimos en la lección anterior.
Todo esto es muy bueno porque esta descripción de la
medición proyectiva es más limpia de cierta manera y vemos que encaja en
esta imagen más general.
Aquí hay un ejemplo más de
una medición proyectiva.
Este es una medición de dos qubits.
Para esta medición
tenemos dos proyecciones y, por lo tanto, dos posibles
resultados que son cero y uno.
Las proyecciones están definidas
en términos de los estados de Bell como ves aquí.
La primera proyección es
sobre el espacio generado por los tres estados de Bell simétricos y la segunda proyección es
sobre el espacio unidimensional
generado por el estado Psi-, que es el antisimétrico, o en otras palabras el
que se multiplica
por un signo menos si
realizamos una operación de intercambio en los dos qubits.
Veremos más adelante en la serie por qué esta es una medición interesante.
Por ahora, es solo un ejemplo
que conecta con algo que hemos visto antes,
que es la base de Bell.
Una nota final sobre las mediciones proyectivas es que siempre que tengas
una medición proyectiva, siempre puedes implementar esa medición
usando operaciones unitarias y
mediciones en la base estándar.
Para este ejemplo particular de
una medición, por ejemplo, podemos construir un quantum circuit que implemente la medición
como ves aquí.
Imaginamos que los dos
qubits superiores son los qubits que estamos midiendo con
esta medición proyectiva y lo que podemos hacer es
introducir un nuevo qubit
que empieza inicializado
al estado cero. Realizamos un Hadamard gate
seguido de un Fredkin gate, seguido de otro Hadamard gate,
y si medimos este qubit inferior usando una medición en la base estándar, el efecto será exactamente el mismo que si hubiéramos medido los dos qubits superiores
con la medición proyectiva
de este ejemplo.
Obtendremos exactamente las mismas probabilidades para los dos resultados y el efecto que la medición tiene sobre los dos qubits superiores
será el mismo también.
Eso no es nada obvio. Se necesita un análisis para verlo y ese análisis no se muestra aquí.
Como ya he sugerido, examinaremos más de cerca
esta medición en particular en una lección posterior y por ahora
es solo un ejemplo.
El punto importante que hay que llevarse es que algo así
es siempre posible para cualquier medición proyectiva, así que en realidad no ganamos
ninguna capacidad adicional
al introducir mediciones proyectivas, pero es un concepto muy útil y a menudo hablaremos
de mediciones proyectivas
a medida que avancemos en la serie. La última parte de esta lección trata sobre algunas limitaciones importantes
de la información cuántica
y lo que podemos hacer con los quantum circuits.
La primera limitación, que quizás no es tanto una limitación como una degeneración, tiene que ver con el problema de las fases globales
que mencioné hace un momento. Esta es la definición de lo que queremos decir cuando hablamos de una fase global.
Si tenemos dos vectores de estado cuántico, Psi y Phi, tales que uno de ellos es
igual al otro multiplicado por algún número complejo alfa,
entonces decimos que los estados
difieren por una fase global o, alternativamente, que son equivalentes salvo una fase global.
Observa que, dado que los vectores de estado cuántico tienen norma euclidiana igual a uno, la única manera en que esta
ecuación puede ser verdadera
es si el valor absoluto
de este número complejo es igual a uno, por lo que alfa
debe estar en el círculo unitario.
Imaginemos que tenemos
dos estados cuánticos como estos que difieren por una fase global y supongamos que medimos el estado Phi
con una medición en la base estándar.
La probabilidad de obtener cualquier resultado A viene dada por esta expresión aquí, y si sustituimos
alfa por Psi en lugar de Phi,
lo cual podemos hacer porque estamos
suponiendo que son iguales, obtenemos esta probabilidad.
Y si simplificamos usando el hecho de que alfa está en el
círculo unitario complejo, obtenemos esta probabilidad.
Recuerda que esta es la probabilidad de que medir Phi dé el resultado A, pero ahora vemos que
esta es exactamente la misma que la probabilidad de que medir
Psi dé el resultado A,
así que no hay absolutamente
ninguna diferencia en las probabilidades de los distintos resultados para los dos estados.
Un argumento similar nos dice de manera más general que para cualquier medición proyectiva, las probabilidades son también idénticas.
Así que midiendo no podemos
distinguir entre dos estados que
difieren por una fase global, ni siquiera en sentido estadístico.
Por último, si aplicamos cualquier operación unitaria
al estado Phi, entonces, de nuevo sustituyendo, lo que obtendremos es exactamente
el mismo número complejo alfa
multiplicado a lo que obtendríamos aplicando la misma operación unitaria
al estado Psi.
Así que los dos estados seguirán
difiriendo por una fase global.
La conclusión es que los dos estados son completamente indistinguibles, así que en realidad no hay
ninguna diferencia entre ellos
en términos de lo que podríamos
aprender sobre ellos realizando operaciones unitarias
y mediciones, y por esta razón,
consideramos que estos dos
estados son equivalentes o, si lo prefieres, que estas son simplemente dos posibles representaciones vectoriales distintas
del mismo estado cuántico.
Como dije al
comienzo de la discusión, es básicamente una degeneración
en cómo los estados cuánticos se describen mediante vectores de estado cuántico.
En cualquier caso, lo que esto significa es que podemos
simplemente ignorar las fases globales, tal como hicimos efectivamente cuando describimos las mediciones en la
base estándar
como mediciones proyectivas. Por cierto, esta degeneración solo ocurre en la descripción simplificada
de la información cuántica.
Cuando describimos los estados cuánticos
usando matrices de densidad, como haremos en la
tercera unidad de la serie, tendremos una representación matricial única
para cada estado cuántico. El problema de las fases globales
simplemente no aparece en la descripción general
de la información cuántica.
Es otro aspecto atractivo más
de la descripción general de la información cuántica,
al que sigo aludiendo, pero de todas formas, las fases globales no nos molestarán
porque podemos ejercer nuestra
libertad de ignorarlas.
Aquí hay un ejemplo muy rápido
para asegurarnos de que la noción de fase global está clara.
Si tenemos un estado menos, y menos uno por un estado menos, entonces estos dos estados
difieren por una fase global, y en particular tenemos
alfa igual a menos uno.
Por otro lado, si tenemos un estado más y un estado menos, entonces no tenemos dos estados
que difieran por una fase global.
Estos son vectores ortogonales, así que son linealmente independientes.
Decir que dos vectores de estado cuántico difieren por una fase global
es equivalente a decir que los vectores son linealmente dependientes,
así que definitivamente estos vectores
no difieren por una fase global.
Es cierto que la única diferencia es que este signo más
se convierte en este signo menos, pero eso es lo que llamamos una
diferencia de fase relativa.
Eso es distinto de una fase global porque no estamos
multiplicando todo el vector por un número complejo.
Y esto es coherente con el hecho de que podemos distinguir
entre estos estados; en particular, si
aplicamos una operación Hadamard
y luego medimos, veremos un cero si el
estado era un estado más y un uno si el estado era un estado menos.
La siguiente limitación de la información cuántica que veremos en esta lección
es el teorema de no clonación.
Aquí hay un enunciado del
teorema de no clonación, y este enunciado particular
del teorema es bastante concreto y específico,
lo que facilitará hablar sobre él. Hay otras formas más generales de formular el teorema de no clonación,
pero nos centraremos en este por ahora.
Suponemos que tenemos dos sistemas X e Y que tienen el mismo conjunto de estados clásicos.
que consiste en los
enteros del cero al D-1, donde D es al menos dos.
En realidad no importa mucho cómo se llamen los estados clásicos, pero eligiendo estos nombres nos será más sencillo.
Lo más importante
aquí es que haya al menos dos estados clásicos distintos, es decir, que no nos preocupemos por el caso
trivial y poco interesante
en que solo tenemos un estado clásico.
Lo que dice el teorema es que no existe ninguna operación unitaria U que podamos aplicar a X, Y de modo que si inicializamos
Y al estado cero,
efectivamente copiemos o clonemos
estados cuánticos arbitrarios de X.
Si analizamos esta
expresión de aquí de forma aislada, lo que dice es que para toda elección de un vector de estado cuántico Psi de X,
aplicar U a Psi tensorial
con el estado cero nos da Psi tensor Psi, o en otras palabras dos
copias independientes de Psi,
eso es lo que significaría si pudiéramos clonar estados
cuánticos, y lo que dice el teorema es que esto no es posible.
Puedes pensarlo
en términos de circuits, y lo que dice el teorema es
que nunca podrás crear un gate o un circuit
que funcione como ves aquí.
Donde una copia del estado Psi entra junto con una colección
de Qubits inicializados y se producen dos copias de Psi.
Puedes hacer esto para ciertas
elecciones del estado Psi, pero nunca podrás crear
un circuit que funcione así para todo estado cuántico Psi,
y eso es lo que dice el teorema.
Es bastante fácil demostrar
este teorema; de hecho, básicamente se reduce al hecho de que la transformación que buscamos
no es lineal,
pero las operaciones unitarias son
lineales, así que simplemente no puede funcionar.
Aquí tienes un argumento con un poco más de detalle.
Supongamos que tenemos una operación unitaria U que clona los estados
de la base estándar, Ket 0 y Ket uno.
Sabemos que los estados clásicos
cero y uno deben pertenecer a nuestro conjunto de estados clásicos porque D es al menos dos.
Pero esto significa, por linealidad,
que si X está en un estado más, que podemos escribir así,
el resultado es esta combinación lineal de estos dos estados de aquí.
Sin embargo, ese no es el comportamiento correcto. El requisito sobre U es que
U clone el estado más,
lo que significa que tenemos que
satisfacer esta ecuación de aquí.
Estos dos estados no son
iguales, así que no funciona, y eso es todo.
Solo unas pocas observaciones adicionales
sobre el teorema de no clonación.
Primero, este enunciado del
teorema de no clonación es absoluto en cierto sentido.
Simplemente dice que no existe una operación unitaria U que funcione exactamente
así.
Así que podrías preguntarte si
existe o no una operación unitaria U que
haga esto de forma aproximada con respecto a alguna manera de describir
una aproximación al enunciado. Hay diferentes
nociones de aproximación que podrían ser de interés
y veremos un par
de ellas en la tercera unidad de la serie, pero para estas diferentes
nociones de aproximación,
hay enunciados cuantitativos
del teorema de no clonación que imponen límites estrictos sobre qué tan bien puedes clonar de forma aproximada.
Una segunda observación es que copiar o clonar estados de la base estándar
sí es posible.
Por ejemplo, un gate Controlled NOT copia los estados de la base estándar de un Qubit.
Esto no contradice
el teorema de no clonación. La clave está en que clonar en el sentido del teorema de no clonación requiere
que esto funcione no solo
para los estados de la base estándar,
sino para todos los estados.
Un gate Controlled NOT
desde luego no clona un estado más, por ejemplo.
Y por último, vale la pena señalar que también existe un teorema de no clonación para
los estados probabilísticos.
Simplemente no es algo
de lo que la gente hable o le importe.
Si alguien elige
un bit al azar, por ejemplo, según alguna forma arbitraria de
asignar probabilidades a los dos valores y
luego te entrega ese bit,
claro que no hay forma de obtener dos muestras independientes
de ese bit aleatorio.
Simplemente no sabes cuáles
son las probabilidades.
Puedes copiar el bit igual que un Controlled NOT
copia los estados de la base estándar, pero eso no es lo mismo que clonar el estado probabilístico.
Simplemente no tienes suficiente
información para hacer eso. Cualquier bit aleatorio que te hayan dado no te dice cuáles eran
las probabilidades.
Es solo un bit.
La imposibilidad de clonar
un estado probabilístico se desprende exactamente del mismo razonamiento que en el entorno cuántico.
Clonar es un proceso no lineal, mientras que las operaciones probabilísticas, al igual que las operaciones unitarias, son lineales.
De todas formas, no es sorprendente
que no podamos clonar un estado probabilístico y
de algún modo no es tan interesante como el hecho de que no podamos
clonar un estado cuántico,
pero el punto es simplemente observar que esto no es un fenómeno
exclusivamente cuántico.
La última limitación
de la información cuántica que discutiremos en esta lección es que no es posible
discriminar perfectamente
dos estados cuánticos que no son ortogonales.
Otra forma de decirlo
es que si dos estados cuánticos pueden discriminarse perfectamente, entonces tienen que ser ortogonales.
Lo que queremos decir cuando hablamos
de una discriminación perfecta de dos estados cuánticos, Psi y Phi, es que hay alguna
forma de distinguirlos
sin ninguna posibilidad de error.
En términos del modelo de circuit cuántico, podemos expresar esto como
ves aquí en la pantalla.
Tenemos alguna operación unitaria U, que podría implementarse
como un circuit cuántico o podríamos simplemente pensar en U de forma abstracta
como una operación unitaria,
y como entrada U toma el estado Psi o el estado Phi
junto con un conjunto de Qubits inicializados, que puedes pensar como Qubits de espacio de trabajo que de alguna manera ayudan en este
proceso de discriminación.
Después de aplicar U, el Qubit superior se mide con respecto a una medición de base estándar y aquí está la parte de discriminación perfecta.
Si el estado de entrada era Psi, entonces la medición debe
dar el resultado cero, el 100% de las veces, y si
el estado de entrada era Phi,
entonces la medición debe
dar el resultado uno, también con un 100% de probabilidad.
No importa cuál sea el
estado de estos otros Qubits después de aplicar U.
Lo único que importa es este bit que obtenemos de la medición, porque ese es el bit que nos dice cuál de los dos estados teníamos al principio.
Para algunas elecciones de estados, Psi y Phi, será posible realizar una discriminación perfecta como
esta, y para otras no lo será.
Y lo que observaremos es que
si es posible hacer esto, entonces Psi y Phi tienen
que ser estados ortogonales
y eso significa que si Phi y
Psi no son ortogonales, no puedes discriminarlos perfectamente.
Así que veamos por qué una discriminación perfecta implica ortogonalidad.
Empezaremos escribiendo dos ecuaciones que expresan lo que
expresan estos dos diagramas.
Si pensamos en el estado cuántico que obtenemos después de aplicar U a un
conjunto de Qubits inicializados junto con el estado Psi,
vemos que tiene que
tener esta forma aquí, donde Pi cero es algún vector de estado cuántico que representa el estado
de todos estos Qubits
excepto el superior. No tenemos ninguna información
sobre este estado cuántico, Pi cero, podría ser cualquier cosa,
pero sabemos que el estado completo
tiene que verse así, porque esa es la única
forma de garantizar que la medición dé
el resultado cero el 100% de las veces.
Y tenemos una ecuación análoga
para el segundo caso.
Esta vez el Qubit superior
tiene que estar en el estado uno y, similar a Pi cero, el
estado Pi uno puede ser cualquier cosa.
Y además de no tener
información sobre Pi uno, tampoco sabemos nada
sobre la relación entre Pi cero y Pi uno.
Por lo que sabemos, estos son simplemente dos
estados cuánticos arbitrarios.
Lo que podemos hacer a continuación es
multiplicar ambos lados de estas ecuaciones por
ambos lados por U dagger, es decir, la transpuesta conjugada de U.
Y si hacemos eso, obtenemos las dos ecuaciones
que ves aquí.
Estamos usando el hecho de que U dagger por U es la matriz identidad.
Por eso no vemos U ni U dagger en el lado izquierdo de ninguna ecuación.
Y ahora podemos considerar el producto interior entre Psi y Phi.
Es lo mismo que el producto interior
de Psi y Phi multiplicado por el producto interior
del estado L cero consigo mismo
porque el producto interior de
cualquier estado consigo mismo es uno, y eso incluye el estado L cero.
Y ahora si miramos nuestras dos ecuaciones, vemos que esta expresión aquí es igual al producto interior de los vectores
representados por las dos ecuaciones. Y en particular, es el producto interior entre los lados izquierdos
de estas ecuaciones.
Así que podemos igualmente
expresar este producto interior como el producto interior de los vectores representados por los lados derechos
de estas ecuaciones,
porque el lado izquierdo es
igual al lado derecho en ambas ecuaciones.
Así que obtenemos esta expresión aquí, que es el producto interior
de los dos lados derechos de las ecuaciones o, de manera equivalente,
es la transpuesta conjugada del primero multiplicada por el segundo.
U por U dagger es igual
a la matriz identidad, porque U es unitaria, así que desaparece.
Y podemos simplificar un poco para obtener el producto de
estos productos interiores.
Ahora recuerda que no sabemos nada sobre la relación
entre Pi cero y Pi uno, así que no sabemos cuál
es su producto interior.
Eso es un misterio para nosotros. Pero sea lo que sea, lo estamos multiplicando por el producto interior de Ket 0 y Ket uno, que es cero.
Así que el resultado final es que
obtenemos el valor cero, pero eso es lo que queríamos demostrar: que el producto interior entre
Psi y Phi es igual a cero.
Así que los dos estados son ortogonales.
Así que no te molestes en intentar
discriminar perfectamente dos estados cuánticos no ortogonales, simplemente no puedes hacerlo.
Existe un recíproco del
enunciado que acabamos de demostrar, que es que los estados cuánticos ortogonales siempre se pueden discriminar perfectamente,
y esto no es difícil de
ver si hacemos uso de un hecho que mencioné antes en la lección.
Específicamente, si Psi y
Phi son estados ortogonales, entonces una cosa que podemos hacer es elegir cualquier matriz unitaria U
cuyas primeras dos columnas
sean los dos estados.
Sabemos que siempre
es posible hacer esto y no importa
para este propósito exactamente cómo se elija esta matriz unitaria.
Lo único importante es que estas son las dos primeras columnas.
No necesitamos Qubits adicionales. Si simplemente aplicamos U a
los dos posibles estados, obtendremos estos
dos posibles resultados.
Y si medimos el Qubit más alto, que recuerda es el Qubit más a la derecha, obtendremos un cero o un uno
dependiendo del estado con el que empezamos.
Alternativamente, podemos considerar
una medición proyectiva con resultados de cero a uno
definida como ves aquí.
en este caso, la medición
en realidad solo depende de Psi.
Esta medición discrimina perfectamente
Psi de cualquier estado que sea ortogonal a Psi.
Si medimos Psi con respecto a esta medición proyectiva, obtendremos el resultado
cero con probabilidad uno, como muestran estas ecuaciones.
Y para cualquier estado Phi
que sea ortogonal a Psi, obtendremos el resultado
uno con probabilidad uno.
No voy a repasar los
detalles de estos cálculos, pero si te interesa, te animo a que los trabajes
por tu cuenta.
Y con eso concluye la lección tres. Cubrimos mucho
material en esta lección, incluyendo quantum circuits,
productos internos y ortonormalidad, proyecciones y mediciones proyectivas, el hecho de que las fases globales no importan,
el teorema de no clonación, y el hecho de que los estados no ortogonales no pueden discriminarse perfectamente, mientras que los estados ortogonales sí pueden.
Espero que te unas a mí para
la cuarta lección pronto, que es la última lección de
la primera unidad de la serie.
En la cuarta lección, hablaremos de tres
ejemplos muy importantes: la teletransportación, la codificación superdensa,
y la desigualdad CHSH o juego CHSH, como se le describe a veces.
Hasta entonces, adiós,